Britain is one of Europe's leading
economies and a global player in the
world of finance London has long had
closed trade ties with the US government
study recently found that the British
economy is set to profit in the region
of up to 10 billion pounds annually from
T tip and after reassurances that the
government-sponsored national health
service will be shielded from negative
fallout the British have a very relaxed
view on the issue Spain is a key
supplier of fruit and vegetables for all
of Europe so its farmers who could
profit most from a new free trade
agreement here in Spain tea tip has no
relevance for a broader public there are
some left-wing groups and parties and
environmental organizations who are
trying to lobby against a free trade
agreement but it's hard for them to find
their audience in Hungary economic
growth has been flat over the past few
years and since the new government took
power the country has mainly been
focused on domestic issues since the
banking system is with more than fifty
percent back in Hungarian hands since
recently this is something which is also
very important for the government now
and in such political climate it's rare
that people are discussing openly about
the goods and the bads of a free trade
agreement between the EU and the United
States meanwhile negotiations on the
trade agreement are underway in Brussels
you Commission insists that the free
trade agreement is a huge chance for the
European economy but of course there are
many opponents also here in Brussels for
example in the European Parliament where
many members of parliament fear for
European standards for example consumer
protection standards or employment
standards and the fact that many of the
negotiations take place behind closed
doors doesn't really help because
transparency might be the one thing to
help disperse fears in Europe